cool for the summer was this your
experience falling in love with a woman
I actually released it when before I
came out as bisexual at the time did
management tell you not to come out as
bisexual no no I just grew up in a
Christian home and was kind of
traumatized in that area didn't want to
come out and when I came out
um my dad was like yeah you have a song
called cool for the summer like you sat
them down and said look I like women I
like men we were on a plane we were
going to a show and I was like I have to
tell you something and this is my
stepdad we're talking about right I was
like I have to tell you something and he
was like what is it and I was like I
like girls too and he was like yeah
listen to cool for the summer it's like
okay that was really easy isn't it
amazing that you have all these fears
and everything and then all of a sudden
you tell people they don't give a
really yeah and my mom didn't either she
was just like I just want you to be
happy and I was like wow I built it up
in my head did you go to the woman you
wrote it about did you say no I wrote a
song about you no do you think she knows
you wrote this about her
um no oh how honored she would be you
don't want to give her that you don't
want to say you know I just want you to
know let's say her name is I don't know
Susan
sometimes I write songs and I just leave
them let them be I just feel bad for her
she's not someone famous right
um what if she is I'm curious is she
oh she is yeah well then you should then
why wouldn't you tell her I'm in a
relationship now and I feel like that
would be inappropriate yeah maybe you're
right yeah you know what you're right
yeah miss the moment yeah you'll screw
things yeah I missed the moment should
have said it back then this was never
public no oh my God you two singing
around you with another famous woman
sneaking around
but now it'll become like the You're So
Vain thing who is the song I know I know
people are gonna Wonder now
laughs